[Applause]
the fascination with
going to space is this a big dick
contest with elon
is he really curious what advantage does
that give them
i i think engineers want bigger problems
and
i think it's like like
i think of them looking into space is
why
is for the same reasons why i became
interested in sustainability okay at
some point
if it looks like you can kind of do
things then you start questioning
and you start feeling because when you
start off in your career you're young
you're kind of like am i capable can i
even hang
in the arena that i'm pursuing yeah once
you sort of
get validation and you feel that you can
do that you're like well what is the
legacy what am i actually here
to achieve other than just being another
[ __ ] that's doing the same thing as
all these other [ __ ] right
making a good living but i look at them
and i'm at that level but like
is it really that meaningful or
important yeah so i do think that
genuine
that's that sort of legacy pursuit of
being a
multi-planetary species is like i don't
think that's [ __ ] i think they're
sincere about that
okay but i think the motivation to
pursue it aggressively and lose a lot of
money at it is the ego driven part
so i think things can be ego driven and
sincere at the same time
but is this the first thing that we've
seen like bezos do
that isn't uh
increasing his current businesses
like everything that he's done that you
said before the space exploration
each one of those fields improves his
ability to
sell goods right right or he's going to
get into the good itself
right which is the healthcare but space
how the [ __ ] does that help him sell
books sneakers cabinets et cetera
clothes i make sense like
if you have for example like um they do
the amazon prime they do
the video right or what is it they do
right movies tv it doesn't matter
i'm sure at a certain point you're going
to be able to pause the program
see the person's shirt and you will be
able to link
to where you can buy that shirt on
amazon if it exists on amazon right if
that doesn't already exist right now
so it's a perfect advertisement for
selling the goods how the [ __ ] does
space help that
i'm not sure it does i think it's highly
possible that they're post-rationalizing
it
so it might be that you decide yeah i
want to go to space
yeah and why is it good and then you're
like how can i make money
to fund it along the way and it might be
with some sort of telecommunications
satellite system stuff like that uh the
other thing that i think is interesting
is there's a considerable about
amount of money in government contracts
and yeah
amazon and it's kind of funny right like
i'm i'm interested in the gossip of
these things because one
we use these platforms on a daily basis
for our work
we both put videos up on youtube so
google what happens with google matters
to us
use instagram and facebook for
monetization i care what facebook is
doing
and i use amazon affiliates for moving
products and stuff like that
in my videos so i use these things
and the people that are running them are
kind of interesting but still very
flawed
so you can feel both like envious of
their success and occasionally superior
like
what the [ __ ] is this idiot doing yeah
yeah and i think that's the most
intriguing thing
is when somebody is better at something
or
in a situation it's kind of like they
get your attention because you're like
i'm not i'm not quite there yet
yeah yeah yeah you have more money uh
but at the same time
but they made mistakes
we love seeing people more successful
than us in situations that justify us to
temporarily call them an idiot yes
um yeah so i think the space thing is
partially ego driven
but yeah it doesn't mean that it's bad
and it's still probably good and i
they might have a million possibilities
for how they can monetize it
yeah and i don't think their vision has
to be perfect i think with any of these
tech companies
they tried a lot of things exactly
because they weren't sure what was going
to make the most money
right and then they slowly cut away the
things that don't work yeah i mean
remember google glass yeah yeah and now
like google's not pushing it and that's
yeah that's
a good thing that's what google just
can't make products they're great at
software but hardware forget it like
oh they make phones for poor people
but it's like it's good that they try
right like
you've got to try things that are
different and then you also have to give
up on them
when it's not clear or when they're
clearly not working but don't you think
that like
just back to the google thing don't you
think that's an investment in like a
cool
and i'm gonna put that under quotes like
apple seems to care about cool they
seem to care about dictating culture
whereas google's like we just want the
information we want the data and then
we'll put things out based on
information data
i'm sure some nerds crunch some [ __ ] and
they're like people want glasses that do
things
and then they did it out whereas apple's
rolled out would have been completely
different for that i think our first
thing would have been aesthetic
apple is is a luxury company right like
yeah it's a it's a luxury brand
with a limited amount of offerings this
is interesting about it right so if you
look at like them
if you were to map the data of where
people are using ios versus android
and map it over new york all and and
it directly correlates to real estate
value yeah
like queens yeah there's a lot a lot of
green text
and then like manhattan it's all it's
all i always
yeah um but they're also really
fanatically
great about how well the hardware works
like yeah and
i always love it when people like apple
those idiots they got rid of my
headphone jack
yeah and then i just saw that the sales
on airpods
just airpods yeah the revenue from
airpods
was greater than uh the revenue from
spotify snapchat and twitter combined
yeah
just that one product yeah and so it's
like it's always funny to me when people
oh what's apple doing they totally
screwed up yeah they're not
it's never gonna be as good why do they
keep making things worse this keyboard
sucks and it's like
bro relax like they just they know
they're doing right
they were setting it up they knew they
were moving towards the
the wireless airpods they knew that they
were going to slowly get rid of that and
they're just
setting you up one step at a time down
the road
so it's really i think the big
difference though
google does more research like they have
so many initiatives and you can go on
like their websites and their see what
their employees are doing yeah
they're trying so much random stuff like
the other day someone
from i did a talk at google right before
the pandemic
yeah i met a bunch of employees and
they're working on like
artificial intelligence and art groups
yeah make sure you're good
and i'm like what does that have to do
with like
search engines and stuff like that but
they're almost run like a university
where they just have all these things
they just try to keep the smart kids
happy give them a playground so they can
mess around
yeah give them free cafeteria food and
just keep collecting that intelligence
but they're not always sure where
they're going with it where i think
apple's like very like
we make the best products in the world
that have incredibly high margins
but they're not even the best what's
better i thought that the android phones
were better i thought they were
like in terms of physical
characteristics and the quality of it oh
you're like one of the mega pixels
guys like this i mean look that's what
they tell me right like anybody that has
one of those phones always like oh
there's
so many more megapixels and the video
quality is so much better and this has
six cameras instead of four cameras
i'm not going to use it because it's not
seamless with my lifestyle and apple's
got me hooked right but in terms of
actually breaking it down like if you
want to look at statistics right like we
can see one basketball player is better
than another
there are certain basketball players
that are better than allen iverson i
want to hoop like iverson true
right it's one i think best is tricky
right because it's different for
different people but i would say that
the way they advertise and talk about
their products is telling
so if you see like a google or android
like for the pixel yeah it'll be like
this many megapixels they give you stats
yeah yeah if you see the billboard for
the iphone they go they just show you
the photo
we took this with an iphone right yeah
yeah and it's just it's a great photo
yeah yeah and it's so tell it's so it's
so scoreboard related
it's like oh you average that many
points that's cute how many pixels yeah
yeah
and there's no right answer to that yeah
and it doesn't mean that megapixels
aren't valuable but it's just a
different approach
and clearly it's resonating better with
a higher end audience but you don't
think that they're attacking not
attacking but like attaching themselves
to
to culture and that's why they end up
winning yeah
like that's the move right yeah also
android just doesn't understand culture
they don't have an ambassador either
like who the [ __ ]
this is the weirdest thing about about
google that i don't understand
you know who runs google i don't
most people don't we know who runs
tesla we know who runs amazon we know
who runs facebook
we know who runs apple we don't know
anything about
[ __ ] google well it's also more
complicated too because like uh
larry and sergey the sort of founders
are still kind of in the scene and on
the board
but they have a uh a ceo sooner
uh who's technically the ceo but there's
it's a more complicated structure but
they're not a celebrity run company and
they don't care about using the
celebrity equity
to bolster their company because they've
won like apple's still competing
like apple doesn't own the greatest
market share in terms of like iphones
around the world
i imagine google owns search i
i would say that apple's won okay now
let's look at this way right take a
company like spotify
have they won in terms of they sell the
most phones have they won in the way
that google
has won i think they've wanted the fact
that the iphone is the most successful
product ever created in the history of
mankind
wait a minute yeah more successful than
the condom
how many of those do you use
it's been a decade it's been a long time
not very user friendly but i did use
them quite a bit
you